[Music]
all right guys we're here we're here
yeah we did we miss her she already here
no no that's good that's good
nice the big day momma's ain't gone for
three weeks and she's coming home from
California they wouldn't let her come
home and so they could make sure that
she wouldn't have no nerve damage and
I'm really scared that I'm not even
gonna recognize who she is
her you know double chin is gone her bat
wings are gone she's gonna like a
completely different person
y'all seen her no Jen said anything well
then we all get the shock value maybe
she just wants the surprises oh look at
me I don't even remember what gene looks
like without a turkey neck hasn't she
had that thing forever well no she was a
really cute kid so you think she's going
all her healings gonna be done for the
wedding yeah I think so that way she
won't be hurting I don't want to hurting
for the wedding I want her to be like
comfortable in her own skin by then and
everything healed up hopefully she'll be
here soon so it's coming in the door Wow
I'm home
oh my lord
[Music]
you